this video is sponsored by Masterworks
skip the waitlist and join Masterworks
today by using the link in the
description
there are things that no one will ever
know about you you will live your life
possessing qualities thoughts and
feelings that no one else nothing else
will ever know
like a lock box of secrets about the
natural world the phenomena rising out
from the universe inside your head will
be exclusively yours until the end of
everything the things you never tell
anyone the things you never admit the
things you can never access or share
because you don't have the words will
all remain forever real but hidden parts
of the cosmos
in part this is profoundly beautiful we
each have secrets kept between us and
configurations of the universe's matter
that always keeps its promise to never
tell
but also this can be incredibly
isolating
[Music]
there is so much in our mind that no one
will ever touch that will never be
consoled will never be reassured we'll
never hear anyone say I understand
so much of what we think and feel is
simply too odd or disconcerting to share
with anyone and even if we do it's often
filtered into some vague watered-down
version
it isn't our fault the mind seems
inbuilt with this filter and sensitivity
a need for acceptance and favorable
appearance our skull is merely armor for
the Pink naked pasty body inside of it
afraid of the world seeing it for what
it really is
even if you are someone who considers
yourself very open confident forthright
there are undeniably still things that
no one knows about you thoughts and
reactions that you recoil at and push
back down into the unconscious mind and
even the things you do share oftentimes
still no one ever fully understands what
you mean and then of course there are
all the things that you don't even
really understand about yourself and all
the things you can't share even if you
wanted to all the strange Sensations we
might refer to as weird or anxious or
tired or sad or anything else never
really get anywhere close to the
abstract Kaleidoscope of what it is
really like inside your head words
always fall flat at the front of what
something is really like restrained by
language's limited ability to share only
the symbols of things and never what
things really are
one can only wonder what we don't know
about ourselves as a species
collectively that everyone experiences
feels or thinks but no one does or can
share because we lack the words or means
to do so
near the end of his life The prominent
and socially active German writer Gerta
said no one has ever properly understood
me I have never fully understood anyone
and no one understands anyone else
We Are All Made of different particles
constructed at different times and
places sent off on different tracks of
time and space no one ever has and no
one ever will experience the exact
physical track you are traveling across
the universe we are all the soul
conductor on a train with no passengers
the byproduct of this is an inherent
existential loneliness a background home
we all hear unsure of whether or not
anyone else does or if it's just inside
her head
ironically though this feeling of
separateness of isolation seems to
connect us all
in his novel Infinite Jest David Foster
Wallace wrote everybody is identical in
their secret unspoken belief that way
deep down they are different from
everyone else
we can all relate to the feeling of how
little others can seem to relate to
exactly how we feel and yet somehow
despite all this loneliness is still
often seen as something that only
so-called lonely people feel losers
social outcasts recluses and so on but
in truth the only difference amongst
people in this world is the degree of
loneliness felt of course there are
different degrees loneliness in extreme
forms where someone experiences
isolation or conditions in which their
particular need for social interaction
is not met can be debilitating and lead
to physical and psychological problems
these forms are not necessarily
something to just write off as
inevitable and without reason and
possibility to improve but the point is
even the most socially engaged person
and the most content socially
introverted person still possess some
form of loneliness and it only goes up
from there
loneliness Road psychologist Carl Jung
does not come from having no people
about one but from being unable to
communicate the things that seem
important to oneself or from holding
certain views which others find
inadmissible
arguably we all experience this
inability and Discord on some level and
so we all experience some level of this
sort of existential loneliness and the
perverse societal perception of
loneliness only makes many of us feel
more so a sense that we are uniquely
alone in the feeling and so perhaps what
we need is the occasional reminder that
to feel separate that to feel strange to
feel mad to feel like no one knows
connects us all
we are perhaps the least alone when we
feel we are
one place we can often look to find this
reminder is Art and philosophy in the
broadest sense literature music poetry
paintings or whatever else it is that
shows us that like inside us complex
hidden things are also inside others if
not the same things at least the same
feeling that there are things difficult
to share
creating and consuming art and
philosophy Intimates the abstract or
forbidden parts of ourselves that we
haven't yet really found the people the
courage or the ways to share what we
tell to a page what we hear with a note
what we understand with a stroke are
often secrets we would never or could
never know or tell otherwise
art and philosophy don't help us deal
with our existential loneliness by
reconciling the dissonance between
ourselves and the world but rather by
allowing us to connect over the shared
isolation we all feel
there can never fully be a bridge built
between the world and our mind but
meaningful works of art and philosophy
are like cliffed coasts we can
occasionally stand on to see that there
are others out there stranded and alone
just like us
in the words of David Foster Wallace
literature is one of the few experiences
where loneliness can be both confronted
and relieved drugs movies where stuff
blows up loud parties all these Chase
loneliness Away by making me forget my
name's Dave and I live in a one by one
box of bone no other party can penetrate
or no fiction poetry music and various
ways religion these are the places for
me where loneliness is countenanced
stared down transfigured treated
in lots of ways it's all there is
foreign
[Music]
this video was sponsored by Masterworks
with art being so powerful and alluring
it is no wonder it is often worth so
much recently the renowned and
Innovative artist Albert Olin sold this
painting Doppler build for an incredible
2.7 million dollars and this is during
2022 a year when most people are losing
money left and right either in the stock
market or to inflation or both
interestingly enough most people
spending that much on Art in 2022 are
doing it as an investment according to
Citibank art has a very low correlation
to other Investments like stocks so when
stocks dip art Investments may not as
for inflation art is a compelling option
for this reason as well the last time
inflation was this High art appreciated
more than gold and real estate at an
average of 33 percent per year but how
can you invest in this sort of art
without spending Millions now with
Masterworks you can Masterworks is a
unique platform that lets you invest in
contemporary art by Legends like Picasso
and Banksy but for a fraction of the
full price meaning you can also invest
in this sort of art yourself of course
any investment can fluctuate and this is
not to be taken as Financial advice but
Masterworks is opening up a fascinating
previously elitist Market to all
investors and it's in their best
interest to get the highest return
possible for you from the six paintings
they've sold Masterworks has delivered
an average return of 29 to their
investors including a sale just last
month of that very same Albert Olin
painting mentioned for a 33 return
Masterworks has done so well there's a
wait list to join their 500 000 Plus
members but you can skip it by clicking
the link in the description below
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video
[Music]
[Music]